(audience applaud)
- Our next guest
is a former freestyle motocross competitor
and former professional motorcycle racer.
So like, basically, just has no fear,
neither does his counterpart,
(Kelly giggling)
(audience member laughing)
his organization, they're
meant for each other,
his organization Good Ride
now helps military veterans
get the support and care that they need,
which is incredible,
everybody, please say 'hello'
to Carrie Hart.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Wow!
- How are you?
- I'm awesome, awesome.
- Okay, I've been very much
looking forward to this 'cause
your wife was just here,
- Yeah.
- P!nk, if you don't know,
then you're living under a rock.
But anyway, so when she
was here, we were talking
about lyrics and like
melodies of everything,
like, you know, musically, she's
coming out with a new album
and she wrote a number of
(claps) songs about you
(Kelly laughs)
(Carrie laughs)
and had this to say, when
we asked her how you felt
about those songs, so I just
wanna play this for you.
- Well you have to take
in, like, Carrie's amount
of feelings he can handle
and how much he is actually
thinking about the words
that I'm saying or listening
at all.
- Oh, yeah!
(audience cheering)
- So I think,
- That's fun. (laughs)
(audience applauding)
- I think he's fine, there's
one on the new album that's,
that was a hard day and I
played it for him because
that's fair, he should know
what's being said about him
in the world
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
and he just started giggling
and he is like, "Well, you're welcome."
And I'm like...
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
- All right.
- Is that all accurate?
- Yeah, it's very accurate.
You know, we've been together 21 years,
I have very thick skin.
- That's so cool. (claps)
21 years, yeah, yeah!
- Very little affects me.
- Yeah.
- And you know,
I don't know exactly
what day she's talking
about specifically, but it's probably
- Just plethora! (laughs)
- Just a temperature, yeah.
- It's like, I love that so much,
I love you two as a couple.
Well, you built P!nk a custom
motorcycle, this is amazing.
And I had never heard
of this, maybe you have,
as a push gift?
- Yeah, a push present.
- Yes!
- What's a push gift?
- Those are important.
- Look, Kelly-
- What is a push gift?
- No, what is that?
- Babe, when you have the
baby, you should get a gift.
- Well, you get the baby, right?
- But you should get a gift
(Carrie laughing)
from the man's whose contribution was,
- Do you have to push?
- No, you don't.
- Or can it
be a C-section situation?
- It can be anything.
- Ah, yeah.
- She got a motorcycle!
- What? (laughs)
(Carrie laughs)
- Screw you, P!nk. (laughs)
- Well, I think a lot
of people kind of look like
a dog hearing a high sound,
when they saw that I gave her
a motorcycle, but between me
- I think it's perfectly fits
- And her it makes sense.
- Right right!
- Both of you. (laughs)
- It's different, yeah.
- I want a motorcycle
like that!
- I'm literally
getting my motorcycle license,
this summer.
- Oh, amazing!
- And my producers don't want
me to, but I'm getting it.
(Priyanka laughing)
(audience laughing)
But I just wanna know how
- Go ride.
- To do it, I wanna know how to do it.
And I've been on like, dirt bikes as a kid
but I just love that you gave her, yeah,
you got her a motor-
Did she see it, like beforehand?
Did she know it was coming,
or was it a surprise?
- Not necessarily, like, so,
one of the common threads
with me and my wife is
motorcycles, I mean,
from the day we started dating I said,
"Look, I don't do the passenger
thing, If you wanna ride,
like if you wanna come on the
weekends with me and ride,
you gotta be on your mo own motorcycle."
- Yeah.
- And through our-
- It changes the weight.
- Well, its-
- And I don't like that.
- I mean, (clears throat)
I tell people there's nothing better than
to see the countryside of the
world, than by two wheels,
because you're so in
the moment you're having
to pay attention and you're
seeing the countryside go by
and you're experiencing it
in a totally different way.
- Yeah.
- And so me and her,
like our common thread
as we've gotten older
and different interests
has been motorcycles.
You know, like, it's a
great date night thing,
or if like we're not speaking,
we jump on motorcycles
and go for a ride.
(Kelly laughing)
You know, like anything in between.
- Get it out.
- Yeah, you know.
- Therapy.
- Exactly, get it out.
And so, yeah, so I built
her this motorcycle as,
you know, as a thank you for
being an awesome mom and,
- Yeah.
- You know, birthing my child.
- Yeah,
- Aw!
- I didn't get a present, whatever.
- Amazing.
- So, well,
you brought the bike!
I know, that should have been a red flag.
I honestly don't know that he knew,
but you brought the bike
that you built for P!nk
with you today, so let's go see it.
(upbeat music)
Let's check it out.
- Aw!
- I wanna see it.
(audience cheering)
This is incredible!
- Wow!
(audience cheering)
That's crazy!
- This is so cool!
- Oh, my god.
- No, this is incredible!
So, did y'all go on like
a big drive, like right,
What do you call it, ride?
- Yeah, ride, yeah.
(Priyanka laughs)
- I wanna be cool, I wanna be cool.
- Yeah, don't even worry about it.
- Okay, so you went on a ride and it was,
I heard it was like a big one,
right after she got it right?
- Oh, my gosh.
- Yeah, right,
right after I got the
bike all finished up,
did a few hundred mile
ride up to Napa, you know-
- (gasps) You could have caught a show.
- (indistinct) any time!
- I mean, we actually went
up there
(all laughing)
and did a wine event together.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause my wife makes wine.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, y'all
have your own wine, yeah.
- Yeah, so yeah, so that
was like the first kind
of big ride we did on it and, you know,
she got a lot of use
out of the motorcycle.
Since then, I built
her another motorcycle.
- Yeah.
- And through my charities,
like look, we could
always hoard motorcycles,
which is always fun to do
but at the end of the day,
you know, let's do something,
- Beautiful thing
to raise money.
- Yeah,
let's do something good
with this motorcycle.
I don't want the tires to rot
off of it, so we're gonna-
- Yeah.
- Gift it to a new home!
- All right, well, you're
raffling off this bike
for your organization, Good Ride.
So, can you tell us a little
bit more about Good Ride?
What do you do there?
- So what it is,
so I kind of jumped the fence
from motocross to working
with Indian Motorcycle
about eight years ago.
And so I go to a lot of motorcycle rallies
and a big contingent at
these motorcycle rallies
is either active duty or veterans.
- Hmm.
- So I've always wanted
to do a charity, I've always wanted
to give back a little bit
and so we started doing
this organization where
we host a motorcycle ride
at three different rallies each year,
and it's kind of twofold.
On one side, we're raising
money for veterans and then,
on the other side, we do a
program where we can invite vets
to come out and ride with us.
- Yeah.
- So, it's kind of twofold,
we're showing them a good time
on the day and then we're
also raising money for vets.
- That's so cool, and vets
are in your family, right?
And hers definitely, I know her dad, yeah.
- Yeah, I wasn't really-
I didn't know much about what
veterans kind of go through
when they come home because
there's not much military
in my family, but Alicia's
father, stepmother,
and brother just recently
retired from the Air Force, so
- Yeah,
- I kind of got to experience,
firsthand, like kind of,
unfortunately what happens
when they come home, when
they're done doing their service
and they kind of get
thrown to the wayside.
- Yeah, and reintroduction to society,
'cause it's such a
different, it's a hard thing
- It is.
- To witness as a family
and try and help people,
so it's a beautiful thing
that you're raising awareness
and also this is really rad!
(Carrie laughing)
Whoever gets this,
(all clapping)
this is incredible!
(audience cheering)
To find out
how you can win the motorcycle
Carrie custom built for P!nk,
which I secretly want,
head to "The Kelly Clarkson
Show" Insta story, right now.